[MUSIC]
The day I got an offer to be
a consultant after college,
a good friend told me, girl, you're done.
The hardest part is getting the job.
That got me really excited.
But I also heard this anxious
voice speaking inside my head.
That voice is my inner
critic who I call Nancy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And Nancy kept telling me,
[SOUND] Renata,
I don't think you should be that excited.
You have zero consulting skills.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Nancy was right.
But she calmed down after
all of the training
that every consultant has to get through.
A few years later,
when I met my wonderful partner,
John, I had a strangely
similar experience.
Although my friends tell me, you're done,
the hardest part is
finding the right person.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I was really excited.
But Nancy came back screaming.
Renata, what do you know
about relationships?
Clearly not much because so
far 100% of them have ended.
Ouch
>> [LAUGH]
>> I know.
>> But before I tell you what happened
next, I want to take a quick poll.
Raise your hand if you think that love
is a pretty important part of life.
Everyone, all of us, great.
Now, raise your hand if you feel
like you've been really well
educated on how to love.
None of us.
Let's think about that for a second.
We all value our carriers.
And if you're relatively well educated on
how to succeed, that's how we got here.
But when it comes to love,
which overwhelming research
points as a top predictor of
life satisfaction, health and
wealth, we kind of just wait or
swipe until we find the right person.
We look at the couples around us,
we watch what they do right and
wrong, and
we assume we know how to do right.
But that's like hoping to become
a doctor by watching Grey's Anatomy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
that's what I was thinking
about when I met John.
I felt like I finally
met the right person.
But I didn't feel educated on
how to be the right person.
And I started getting really scared that
I would eventually mess everything up.
And I really didn't want
to mess anything up.
So I started reading every
piece of research, and
every book that I could find, about
the science of love and relationships.
Luckily, John loves reading, so
he followed me down that rabbit hole.
Which is very convenient but
also a little weird.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now we talk about our relationship and
feelings in terms of stuff
like attachment theory.
And the neurobiology of desire and
emotions.
And we haven't even taken.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Even though it might not be sexy to
talk about your relationship in scientific
terms, it's kind of like having food
in your teeth, you really want to know so
you can do something about it.
I have to say though, I try to be really
discreet about my interest in relationship
topics for a long time.
I felt it was super controversial and
frankly too embarrassing to
discuss with anyone else but John.
But then one day, my brother,
Rodrigo, called me to ask.
Hey, is everything okay between you and
John?
And I said, yeah, what's going on?
Well, my brother and
I happen to share an Amazon account,
which sometimes gets awkward.
He was calling because he noticed
the trend in my recent book orders.
Seven Principles for Making Marriage Work.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Your Brain on Love,
Mating in Captivity.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And many,
many other relationship books
that John and I read together.
We don't do Netflix and
chill, we read and chill.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now when my brother called me,
he was also getting an MBA.
So I told him, listen, we're both getting
an MBA because it's valuable, but
it's not always been valuable.
When the MBA was created 100 years ago,
people thought it was crazy that business
was being elevated to the same level
of expertise as law and engineering.
Now it's the most popular
degree in the US.
We finally see value in
business education, and
we have to do the same for love.
Now am I suggesting you create
a formal master's degree in love?
No, but
I am suggesting we all start seeing
ourselves as CEOs of our own love lives.
We know from research,
that couples who thrive and
couples who fail behave very differently.
We also know from research
that just like in business,
there's no formula, but there are tools.
And just like great CEOs,
couples that thrive master tools
that make them better everyday.
Today, I'm going to share my top three
favorites, like a good consultant.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Number one,
choose to see love as a skill.
By far the most important thing
that I've learned from this journey
is that love is not something
that happens to us.
It's a skill.
We can choose to learn,
practice, and master over time.
It's not easy, and
we'll never be perfect, but
seeing it as a skill is the first
step to getting better.
Number two,
choose generosity over judgment.
If you've been the parent of a child or
a puppy, you know what it feels like
to see really unpleasant behavior
with generosity, not judgment.
You understand that
they're still growing up.
But if our partner does something we don't
like, [SOUND] we judge we get offended.
They should be fully grown up by now.
But as long as we are live,
we're all still growing up.
It's easy to love the wonderful about
our partner, but the true love skill
is seeing what's not so wonderful about
them with generosity, not judgment.
Number three, choose to become
an expert on your partner.
We know from neuroscience that if you take
couples who report to still be madly in
love after 25 years and put them through
an MRI machine, when you show them a photo
of their partner, their brain lights up
just like couples who just fell in love.
Which is crazy because that basically
means that the honeymoon phase
doesn't have to be over at the honeymoon.
Couples who stay in love
are couples who stay curious.
Every day they commit to learning
about each other like an expert.
They never stop learning.
It's a bit ironic that we find
a romantic to say things like,
my god,
I know everything about my boyfriend.
Personally, I find it much more romantic
to think about how much more I want to
know about my partner and how much more
of an expert I want to become everyday.
Now these tools are not a checklist,
they are a lifelong practice.
But it's easy to forget that
when we get busy with life.
So I want to leave you with something that
remind myself of being accountable
every day both in business and in life.
As CEOs in love, or business, we're all
given two options every single day.
You can either blame external conditions
for your performance, or you can
take radical responsibility for practicing
the skills that make you better.
Now the question is,
which one will you choose?
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]